you in Cary Grant said of severe truth
in this business we may belong to
different camps but we're all part of
the same Legion and it is indeed a
privilege to announce in the category of
visual effects the nominees are Dennis
Muren Phil Tippett Ken Ralston and Brian
Johnson for Dragonslayer Richard Edlund
KITT west Bruce Nicholson and Joe
Johnston for Raiders of the Lost Ark we
have the envelope please
thank you my partner he would have loved
presenting this award with me he was
somewhat of a visual effect himself and
the winners are Richard Edlund KITT West
Bruce Nicholson and Joe Johnson for
like a Boy Scout I'm prepared this
evening I wrote it down
this year art studio Industrial Light
and Magic received both nominations for
visual effects in accepting this great
award I must pay tribute to our most
talented crew who district who deserve
it as much as we do
to George Lucas Steven Spielberg our
director Frank Marshall the producer and
hard sangeun executive producer thank
you for the opportunity to work on so
exciting a picture and to my fellow
fellow Academy members our gratitude for
the wonderful trophy of all the Oscar